it's time for roses and rose am in
mourning I'm wearing black because
bachelor in paradise is over guys it was
the season finale of bachelor in
paradise
Tuesday night we're here to talk about
it and drink about it okay great so
tonight drink every time somebody cries
because it wasn't just up to Ashley eye
anymore no in the finale crying is for
everyone
so one of our most consistent couples in
paradise grant and lace had some
problems in the finale grandly surgeries
whoo yes it was frightening it's a hard
thing to tell somebody I'm not gonna
propose to you right now because we need
more time grant woke up in the fantasy
suites with a bad feeling I feel very
weird in a bad way a bad feeling bad
feeling and lace is like if you have bad
feeling
why don't we get tattoos if you're just
gonna wake up the next morning and
question if we should be engaged sure
that's a really good question and then
grants bad feeling was so bad he needed
to sit
Jason let him sit so everyone's being
very sweet and saying really sweet
things let's just cut to the proposal I
love that man like I've never loved
anyone
first evan and carly drink so much they
cried so much it was so beautiful it was
so beautiful I mean we went from that
hideous first kiss to this and then we
cut the greens and leis and it's still
like did granted this bad feeling I
don't know if it's too soon Lisa's like
I want to throw up we do to lace um um
we do too and not just because it was
just Labor Day weekend I was in wine
country okay America but then grant
proposes and it's so sweet and he cries
um oh did he cry camera but then grant
proposes and lace cries drink so much
love I'm so happy so many people are
alone in the world but not in bachelor
nation yes hope
okay okay okay okay you got me how we
got crab out from tears the sadness yes
so Nick and Jen they woke up after the
fantasy suite and things seemed pretty
copacetic and then Nick was even like
looking at rings with Neil Lane how many
times I gonna say you were getting
everything never but oh you will me he's
the bachelor jen is walking down the
beach and we hear her saying how much
she loves me I have never felt more
connected with someone and I'm thinking
at this point that maybe Nick's not
gonna propose like guys they didn't have
that much time together we didn't really
think he was gonna propose but I didn't
think he was gonna break up with her I'm
sorry yeah here's what Nick said
someone's telling me to say goodbye
next tears so hard to watch I was really
interested in how this would end up
because the thing is the producers had
to know that it comes out looking pretty
okay because they need on The Bachelor
so we can't like come across looking
like I'm sure when you breaks up with
Jenn and he didn't come across looking
like a jerk because he was crying his
tears look really really little he was
like choke on his own tears and then in
the car he said this man came home
saying I love you to anyone
I think that's right now the biggest
I have to get over what a brilliant
thing to say he is laying out his
struggles as The Bachelor incapable of
saying I love you well I mean oh my god
what a calling card but now let's get
happy again Josh and Amanda Amanda and
Josh ah the couple that moans together
stays together am i right so Jive
propose to Amanda and I can't drink four
tears because like a my own stereotypes
Josh help them back so forcefully
but his proposal was still really sweet
Oh God love love hope dreams America huh
by the way a side note I'm really happy
NYX The Bachelor fed and get the chance
to say that yet I mean oh my god what a
decision he is the right age he has been
on a journey we are gonna see him
continue on that journey his struggle
for love is believable it feels real I
like Nick great choice it's real simple
there's really no words and then and
then we got to get into it on after
paradise we saw some of the couples
again and like oh my god let's drink for
every time something was really sweet
there's just something about her that's
just so attractive Carly sjg be in her
wedding that was really sweet
you're gonna be in mine uh Josh talked
about how much he loves me of his
daughters they love him they're amazing
that was really sweet
Josh addressed his issues with
aggression yep
that had to happen the authoritative
kind of aggressive tone that you carry
that maybe put some people off I'm a
very very passionate person I'm glad it
happened
talk about things yeah Amanda addressed
the moaning finally that just felt like
sweet relief do not do it that much I
would have told him to stop it and then
they said target that's our place right
there oh my god target America bastard
me
have you ever been to target with
someone that you didn't love mmm
Cheers and that wraps up this season of
bachelor in paradise
it was amazing it was so much fun thank
you guys so much for watching with me
and please keep talking me over on
Twitter
we're gonna have a lot of bachelor
nation drama to discuss in the upcoming
months as Nick prepares to become as the
bachelor casting is underway let me know
what kind of lady you think deserves the
vile love it this is such a risky move
you know you can take with you craps be
careful and paradise everybody I don't
know why I started talking like this
probably because I drank so much
I need a stunt double